A lot of the investors rejected us
initially because they perceived
the value of our company to be lower
than their threshold of investment.
What we encountered was that investors
typically fall into two categories.
The long-tail investors and
the unicorn, big fish investors.
The unicorn,
big fish investors for startups,
typically aren't worth the effort,
unless they've been already valued at
unicorn level, a billion dollar company,
essentially a billion dollar startup.
The long-tail investors
are probably your better bet.
They're the ones who will do the $2
to $5 million investments with
a three to five year spread
return on their investment, and
then give you a long enough runway to
actually test out a lot of theories.
In the other case,
with the unicorn investors,
it's typically there after continued
growth valuation over time.
And if at any point during
any future valuation cycle
your valuation drops,
your company's dead in the water,
even though it may be
worth on paper billions.